future president Kanye West lashes out
at Candace Owens saying he's been used
to push a political message he doesn't
support Paul Ryan lashes out a president
Trump over birthright citizenship and
Don Lemon lashes out at white men
meanwhile Americans donate six hundred
thousand dollars to supreme court
justice Brett Kavanaugh for some reason
Democrats can't win for losing and Jon
Stewart slams the media
I'm Brett Kavanaugh and this is the
Michael Knowles show it's Halloween it's
Halloween Senya it's Halloween yeah like
Halloween
I still like Halloween okay I eat candy
I would eat candy with my friends okay
sometimes we would eat candy sometimes
we would eat too much candy and our
stomachs would hurt and our bellies
would ache and our teeth would rot and
we would go to the dentist do you go to
the dentist
Senya have you ever been when do you go
to what dentist do you go to I like
Halloween it's still like Halloween like
candy we have a lot to get to today you
have a whole lot to get to in today's
show we've got we've got Kanye we would
make it through more of that sad to
quote a great man sad
first before we can get into all of it
I've got to make a little money honey
and let's talk about pair of thieves you
know that I regularly invite you into my
boudoir well now I'm going to invite you
even more intimately than that to tell
you about my favorite boxers ever on
average men keep their underwear for
seven long years until they are a
tattered shell of what they once were
don't be that guy pair of thieves is the
most comfortable underwear I have ever
worn hands down they're a proprietary
moisture wicking fabric keeps you cool
and fresh I'll let you use your
imagination on that its proprietary in
the sense that competition has been
trying to copy these guys for four years
and they have failed by the way this is
the best point
at all one of the guys who started pair
of thieves says that all his wife ever
wants to see him in is a pair of they're
super fit briefs and that man's wife is
Jessica Alba it's a true story
so Jessica Alba likes them they're good
enough route but they should be good
enough for you try them out if they're
not instantly your favorite pair of
underwear as they are Jessica Alba's
they will give you your money back for a
limited time this month only our
listeners get 20% off their first order
these boxers are unbelievable get them I
love them I wear them all the time
20% office a great deal pair of thieves
calm / Knowles Kenda WL is 20% off when
you go to pair of thieves calm / anoles
KO wles this month only pair of thieves
calm / knowles kena wles I like pair of
thieves
I still like pair of thieves you know
sometimes I wear them too much and then
they send me more I get to wear
different ones so Kanye West is coming
out now and he says that he feels that
he has been used to spread a political
message that he does not believe him
that's what he says and that's the
headline you've seen the headline that
you've seen it everywhere Kanye West
feels used leaves politics they would
have you believe that he's taken off the
mag ahead burning it in a pile that he's
leaving the Republican Party he regrets
everything he said nothing could be
further from the truth what Kanye
tweeted out is quote my eyes are now
wide open and now realize I've been used
to spread messages I don't believe in I
am distancing myself from politics and
completely focusing on being creative
okay that's fine obviously this guy's
been getting so much hate ever since the
oval office meeting even before that
remember that video of TMZ sitting there
saying take the hat off don't wear the
hat I love we're in the Hat I mean you
can't make me take the head off so he's
been doing that and now the media are
running with this right before the
midterms they're saying Kanye is turning
his back on Trump except you've got to
read down the line as you know all of
these mainstream media articles they
will occasionally put some true things
in there but they buried them at
paragraph 75 so in the reporting on this
what you may have missed is is this
quote from TMZ
Kanye contacted us to make it clear he
did not mention Donald Trump in his
tweets and he's getting out of politics
all together they go on as for being
used he says he was specifically
referring to blech sit and that's it
he was specifically referring to this
new clothing line that Candice Owens is
releasing about black people leaving the
Democrat Party he made quite clear he
was not talking about Trump he's not
talking about himself being a Republican
or him supporting the president he is
simply talking about the exit line of
clothing that Candice Owens has released
okay now Candice I texted Candice once
Kanye tweeted about how he loves her
thinking I texted her and I said I know
the process for canonization takes a
very long time it's usually after
someone dies but you can be up for
sainthood now because she has influenced
the biggest pop star in the world into
supporting the Republican president
that's a great thing and now and he
still seems to support the Republican
president it's like the beer thing I
still I like I like Donald Trump I still
like Donald Trump but he doesn't like
his face being on this blech said
campaign that's fine that's his right
and you know Democrats buy records to
probably blame or Democrats buy pop
records than Republicans so he's got to
watch out a little bit totally get it
Kanye is completely within his rights to
do that this has some conservatives
saying that we never should have
rejoiced when Kanye went to the Oval
Office in the first place don't play
around with Kanye you can't play around
with Kanye now and then be sad when he
turns your bet his back on you or it
turns his back on some part of the
conservative movement or whatever yes we
can why not why not first of all what
he's saying here is that he doesn't want
to be associated with this one little
t-shirt campaign and he's making clear
that he still likes being associated
with the president he still likes drama
okay but also it's fine to take the win
it's fine that when Kanye West came out
their biggest pop star in the world came
and said I love Trump that's a huge win
for conservatives on the culture and and
politically it in so much as Kanye West
has influence over people he will now
influence them to support the Republican
president that's great and then he comes
out and says something else who cares
who cares and we can just move on man
this is really hmm don't typically have
beer at
noon but that's fine that's 5 o'clock
somewhere probably that's absolutely fun
we can we can celebrate that I know the
the thing that's driving this is people
want politics to be like philosophy
people want politics to be just like it
is in theory and it has to be absolutely
perfect let's not let the perfect get in
the way of the good that's one of the
lessons of the trump era president Trump
comes out he ostensibly has no coherent
conservative political philosophy he
hasn't been steeped in the Heritage
Foundation luncheons he probably hasn't
read a lot of Edmund Burke or Michael
Oakshott a Russell Kirk or Hayek or what
all of those books that you're supposed
to read to be the young conservative who
cares he's working in practice and when
he stops working when he says something
that's bad when he goes off the deep end
then we can say ok we got good stuff now
we're gonna move on that's how we can be
about Kanye like Kanye picanha can go do
what every once he can make more videos
in those weird suits singing the most
horrific things I've ever heard in a
song that's fine he can go do that he
already helped us out a little bit and
and let's just take the win let's just
accept that win and move on there are
other other battles to fight one of
those battles is coming up right now
which is this battle over birthright
citizenship so birth birthright
citizenship has been long debated in
American history the legal question here
comes from a case before the Supreme
Court in 1898 called US vs Wong Kim Ark
over whether a child born to legal
permanent residence in the United States
would have US citizenship and was ruled
that yes he would have US citizenship if
this doesn't touch on illegal aliens and
the the legal question over whether
illegal aliens and the children of the
illegal aliens should have birthright
citizenship is much more confused than
that and much more hotly debated there
are two aspects to the question the
legal and the political the on the legal
question now it's being brought up now
we're debating we're debating whether or
not the Fourteenth Amendment
first of all says that the illegal
aliens get birthright citizenship
whether the Fourteenth Amendment should
say that whether Congress has the right
to to
explain what the Fourteenth Amendment
says as has been the case before when
Congress changed the status of Native
Americans for instance under the
Fourteenth Amendment
so maybe Congress has some right to do
it and President Trump in his theatrical
way is now bringing that issue to the
forefront so people either getting
bogged down even conservatives are
getting bugged I'm saying he can't do it
he can't change birthright citizenship
by executive order okay sure fine that's
fine maybe he can't maybe he can maybe
he can at least he's bringing it up you
know so we talked about the legal
question the the political question is
at play here and that is how Donald
Trump is thinking I don't think that
he's studied constitutional law for a
decade but he's very good at politics in
the media aspect of politics and on this
political question the left has
immediately handed Trump a win the
second that he said he might end
birthright citizenship by executive
order and they all lost their minds they
handed him the win they handed
conservatives a win right before the
midterm elections why because now for
the American people they are watching
the Democratic Party say that we do not
support enforcing the law we essentially
support open borders we're going to
prioritize the demands of foreign
nationals over what American citizens
want illegal immigration is intensely
unpopular in the United States not just
on the right but on the left as well not
just among Republicans but among
Democrats as well and Donald Trump
taunts them into defending the
indefensible don't take my word for it
here is Harry Reid former majority
leader of the the Senate majority leader
of the Democrats law I mean I think he's
been a Democrat politician since
probably since 1898 probably since the
Wong Kim Ark case here is Harry Reid in
1993 explaining his position in the
position at that time of the Democratic
Party on birthright citizenship and
illegal immigration if making it easy to
be an illegal alien isn't enough how
about offering a reward for being an
illegal immigrant no son no same country
would do that right guess again
if you break our laws by entering this
country without permission and give
birth to a child we reward that child
with US citizenship and guarantee a full
access to all public and social services
this society provides and that's a lot
of services is it any wonder that
two-thirds of the babies born at
taxpayer expensive country county run
hospitals in Los Angeles are born to
illegal alien mothers that guy sounds
further to the right than Donald Trump
does and that guy is was the head of the
Democrat Party for a very long time the
head of Senate Democrats for a very long
time a lot has changed since 1993 I
don't think that the feeling of the
country really has changed what has
changed is that the Democrat Party is
now beholden to the extreme left the
extreme left wing base which is
typically the Socialist white liberals
like Liz Warren like Lyle Wafaa this
puts them in odds on a number of
questions with identity politics groups
the groups that they have cultivated
through identity politics to to vote
consistently to elect Democrats a lot of
the policies that are favored by the
leadership of the Democrat Party are
deeply unpopular among huge swaths of
the Democrat electorate black voters and
Hispanic voters in particular which is
why you're seeing something of a
realignment which is why you're seeing
according to Rasmussen 40 percent of
black Americans having a favorable view
of the Republican president this is
basically an unheard of number and other
polls back this up this is why you're
seeing support among Hispanics for
Republicans surging it's why you see
Donald Trump doing so well he identifies
these issues and he goes for wedge
issues skilled politicians know this
especially when you get close to an
election time you've got to try to
identify wedges that can separate a
politician from a politician's
supporters illegal immigration is a
perfect one especially with this Caravan
hurtling toward the the us-mexico border
now in the heat of all of this Paul Ryan
has come out and he has said absolutely
not we can't oh you know I'll let Paul
Ryan say it himself
well you obviously cannot do that you
clean out in birthright citizenship with
an executive order we didn't like it
when Obama tried changing immigration
laws the executive action and obviously
as conservatives you know we believe in
the Constitution
you know the conservative I'm a believer
in following the plain text of the
Constitution and I think in this case
the 14th amendments pretty clear and
that would involve a very very lengthy
constitutional process but where we
obviously totally agree with the
president is getting at the root issue
here which is uncheck illegal
immigration absolutely right absolutely
right that what we have to do is get
down to the issue of unchecked illegal
immigration he's not exactly right on
this first part by the way where he says
that the plain text of the Constitution
is clear that the 14th amendment offers
birthright citizenship to illegal aliens
by the way even I was reading through
the Wong Kim Ark decision that we talked
about earlier I was reading through that
today even wonking Kim Ark is far from
clear on this question and perhaps we
should do an entire episode on this
because it's a little complicated but
what you're going to hear from the left
over the next few days is that the issue
was decided most spectacularly by Wong
Kim Ark and that isn't true because in
the discussions in that decision you'll
see questions being raised as to what
happens to the children of hostile or
invading powers people that shouldn't be
there who are in the country illegally
and it seems actually pretty clear from
that decision that those people do not
have citizenship that the the and when
we inherit this right and this concept
from the British that this was the case
in Britain as well so what we've got to
thank our sponsor and make a little
money honey and instill some gratitude
in the United States with Operation
Gratitude
operation American gratitude is so good
that's an organization that was founded
when the founder heard a Vietnam veteran
say in a podcast that he had never been
welcomed home in 50 years since
returning to Vietnam so the goal here is
to deliver thank you cards to two
million Vietnam veterans over the last
five years five years and place a you
are not forgotten card on every Vietnam
War Memorial in America by the
the way when you involve your kids in
these projects you teach some of that
patriotism sacrificing gratitude I think
it's a terrific program we talk about
all those things on the show a lot we
need a lot more of it in the country we
don't need people protesting the
American flag we need people going out
and thanking veterans so you will get in
you're raising Americans dot-com
operation American gratitude package
thank-you cards for five Vietnam
veterans in your hometown an interview
Carter you are not forgotten the card a
Pio WMI a card to remember more than
1600 men missing in action a 58 to 20
card to honor those who made the
ultimate sacrifice 100% of the profits
from Operation American gratitude goes
toward building the freedom never sleeps
business training center in beautiful
Eagle Idaho what a name which is an
on-site six month paid entrepreneurship
program you can make Vietnam veterans
lives a little bit better
you can teach little Americans gratitude
all for less than 20 bucks better yet
when you participate with Operation
American gratitude it makes you fifty
percent more likely to meet George
Washington in heaven this is guaranteed
and go right now to raising American
stat Khan / co f f/a co v fe fe buy your
operation american gratitude kit raising
americans khan / co FFA co v fe fe god
bless america when you look at the issue
is obviously much more complicated and
you can't fit it into a 5 second sound
bite but suffice it to say it is not
plain text it is not plainly clear from
the 14th amendment the issue is far from
decided and it should be decided either
by the courts or by the American people
ultimately probably these things have to
be decided by the American people but
there are different ways to do that all
of which is to say that we should defend
Paul Ryan coming out there and
expressing his point of view because
this is the theatrics this was the point
this is what we you know are you not
entertained is this not why you are here
we are how many days out now from the
midterm elections midterm elections are
on Tuesday less than a week away six
days away now we are seeing the final
fireworks that's why President Trump
released this a few days ago on Axios
HBO it's why we're all talking about it
now it's why you're seeing fireworks on
the left and the right this is an issue
that really fires up Americans broad
and especially conservatives in the
Republican base and he's bringing it up
because it will spark a legitimate
discussion so President Trump in his
typical Trumpy way fired back he said
quote Paul Ryan should be focusing on
holding the majority rather than giving
his opinions on birthright citizenship
something he knows nothing about our new
Republican majority will work on this
closing the immigration loopholes and
securing our border okay typical Trump
right he says to his opponents even his
opponents who are technically on the
same side as him you don't know anything
I know everything and blah blah blah
it's bluster and it's this and it's that
and it's so entertaining we can't help
but watch it and it's focusing our
attention on an issue where our
attention should be focused to maximize
our chances of maintaining the
Republican majority which Trump is or
which Trump is mentioned in that tweet
and it shows a legitimate disagreement
and a legitimate debate that we can have
can president Trump reinterpret or
clarify the 14th amendment through
executive order probably not probably he
can't do it because what's going to
happen is some court is gonna put a hold
on and then it's gonna work its way up
through the court it'll be made perhaps
decided by the Supreme Court
perhaps not perhaps Congress will
intervene and explain explain this
provision but beforehand they'll explain
it and perhaps they'll get away with
that perhaps that would be challenged by
the courts it'll work its way up to the
courts we are far from a solution on
this issue but at least now we're having
a legitimate debate it's that this is a
big winner issue and just pay attention
to the to the theatrics of it you know
we elected president Trump because we
couldn't stop watching the show right he
was the most interesting guy very often
the most interesting guy gets elected
president anyway but we just wanted to
see what comes next we wanted to see
that next episode and we want to see the
next episode here not just for the
fights but for the next the next episode
of what our Constitution means whether
we are one of the few countries on the
face of the earth to grant birthright
citizenship to illegal aliens maybe we
just want to see what happens and and
the mainstream media are falling for it
hook line and sinker we have had some of
the greatest media fails
just in the past week if you missed this
clip I think this is finally evidence
that Don Lemon is working for the GOP
that he's working for the conservative
movement I know he when you watch him
you think this guy is so absurd this guy
is so self humiliating self be clowning
there's no way that he's very earnest
I'm now convinced of it he's a GOP
operative take it away Don Lemon we have
to stop demonizing people and realize
the biggest terror threat in this
country is white men most of them
radicalized right up to the right and we
have to start doing something about them
there is no travel ban on them there is
no ban on you know they had the Muslim
ban there is no white guy ban so what do
we do about that you know we have to
stop drinking beer and we have to
remember that beer is delicious and
quenches your thirst and that's why we
have to stop drinking beer you know that
is what he just said it's we have to
stop demonizing people and remember that
white men are evil we have to stop
demonizing people and we need a travel
ban on white men by the way I don't
think a travel ban is going to do a lot
the white men are already here the white
men are in your midst they are already
in the country obviously who knows even
where to begin on this because just on
the point I hate even to bring it up but
Don Lemon brought it up so I have to
answer just on the point he's saying
that the great terror threat in America
is from white men any way you slice that
assertion it is patently false
there is just no evidence for it
whatsoever to begin violent crime is at
30 year lows there are actually a number
of studies that show that people year
over a year always think that crime is
increasing I think it's just the bias of
living in the present and of watching
media and reading the newspapers crime
violent crime is at thirty year lows
that said when you just talk about
terrorism there have been 97 Islamic
terrorist attacks in the u.s. since
September 11th now fortunately some of
those had been thwarted like the the car
and knife plot at Ohio State in 2016
many of those have not been thwarted
like the pulse nightclub shooting
which was done in the name of Isis and
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi but 97 Islamic
terrorist attacks in the US since 9/11
how many terrorist attacks by white guys
I'm not saying none there have been a
couple there is that kid who shot up the
black church remember him that seemed to
have been a terrorist attack we have to
define our terms - terrorism has a
meaning terrorism is when you target
civilians to advance a political agenda
that's why we have the Geneva
Conventions is to protect civilians
that's why terrorists are not covered by
Geneva Convention protections because
terrorists undermine those very
protections those very incentives
terrorists target civilians to advance a
political agenda so maybe that kid who
shot up the black church could be a
terrorist attack maybe a few others some
are just what would be called hate
crimes some don't really have a
political agenda they just you know a
guy in Pittsburgh hates Jews I can't
exactly see what his political agenda is
I'm not sure that he exactly has one I
suppose it's debatable but that that is
just a horrific crime the Islamic
terrorist attacks are there to advance a
political agenda to advance a terrorist
organization that seeks political goals
that seeks the conquest of territory the
Islamic state and its various agencies
so on that point obviously it's absurd
but let's say that Don Lemon is speaking
just about murder or something just
about killing broadly and that that's
why they're the source of terror
according to the FBI 2016 in the year
2016 I think it's most recent we have
numbers for around 1400 murderers in the
United States were non-hispanic whites
around 1,700 murderers were black
now obviously 12% of the population is
black 80 at night 88 percent of the
population is white but a majority of
the population is white so the murder
rate among just among black black people
is significantly higher now a lot of
this is gang-related a lot of this is in
particular hot beds of crime I am NOT
suggesting any racial correlation any
innate aspect of race that causes
criminality I'm not suggesting that at
all I'm responding to Don Lemon who
suggesting that who brought it up and
one has to respond to it because his
claim is so wildly absurd but just
consider how race obsessed the left is
now that we're even having this
discussion what are the causes of crime
the causes of crime or evil what does it
call what are the causes of evil well
there's the personification of evil and
then there are people who through bad
culture through bad character through
bad situations through bad family
experiences are more likely and more
prone to fall into that sort of evil but
Donna lemon goes right for race and the
left broadly goes right for race
obviously Don Lemon is not a serious
person Don Lemon is the guy when that
Malaysian jetliner went down in 2014 you
remember it was this bizarre mystery
nobody knew where the Malaysian Jo was
it was Don Lemon who went on television
and suggested that there was a
supernatural cause that the jetliner was
abducted by aliens or something we have
known for at least four years that Don
Lemon is not a serious person but it's
very easy to mock him and other media
figures when they're suggesting that ét
abducted a jetliner full of 200 people
it's a little more frustrating when he
starts spouting just sheer racism sheer
uninformed racism on CNN but that's the
left for you and he's not the only one
not to be outdone on racism somebody who
has a lot more to lose joe donnelly in a
very tight race Senate Democrat a really
really tight statistically dead heat in
Indiana listen to what Joe Donnelly
thinks about race we want everybody to
have a chance in Indiana and in America
and my offices reflect that both on the
campaign side and on the Senate side our
state director is Indian American but he
does an amazing job our director of all
constituent services she's African
American but she does an even more
incredible job than you could ever
imagine I I could imagine Joe Donnelly
it's actually to me it doesn't seem
bizarre or out of the realm of
possibility that a black woman could do
a good job I think
perfectly to be expected but to you pal
it's it's absurd that a black woman
could do a good job what does he say
says you know our director of this and
that he's an Indian American but he's
one of the good ones but he does an
amazing job is there the expectation is
that an Indian can't do anything right I
only know of one Indian who can't do
anything right and her name is Elizabeth
Warren all of the other Indians I know
are perfectly confident people perfectly
intelligent and the way that you know
that this wasn't just a slip of the
tongue that this was a little bit more
like a Freudian slip where you say one
thing but mean your mother the way that
you know that this was more of a
Freudian slip as he did it twice in a
row he doubled down on it he somehow he
didn't hear himself saying well he's an
Indian but what's negate sentences buddy
but subvert your expectations well and
she's an african-american but she does a
very good job a much better job than you
could ever imagine then some people
could ever imagine
fine this is pretty devastating because
again look Don Lemon is not a serious
person CNN is not a serious news outlet
so when they push this sensationalist
racist drivel and slander it's what we
expect they're behaving how we expect
them to but Joe Donnelly is supposed to
be a skilled politician who's in a very
tight race who's in the fight of his
political career now in Indiana we'll
see if he can preserve it on Tuesday
then to come out with that statement
it's so sloppy it's so lazy and maybe it
reflects what he actually believes
because if that wasn't enough let's
forget about Don Lemon let's forget
about Joe Donnelly those pipsqueaks that
minor-league let's go right to the queen
bee herself Hillary Clinton in
conversation at the 92nd Street Y with
her opinion on black people
oh I what do you think about him saying
kick them in the shins essentially start
to get to that kind of political that
was Eric Holder Eric oh oh yeah sorry
yeah I know they all look alike no they
now Hillary I if you weren't able to see
that I can just do the impression for
you of Hillary she owes well I know they
all look alike she flies off on her
broomstick they're all laughing and the
whole crowd is like oh ha ha ha
look I've been to a lot of events at the
92nd Street Y the 92nd Street Y in
Manhattan is where all of the cultural
sophisticated people go you know they
all have glasses that look like this and
they all drink Shepley and they go there
and listen to they probably watch TED
Talks you know that kind of thing
they're all left of Lenin they're all
laughing oh ha ha Hillary you made a
good joke what's interesting about this
Jo look she made a joke and she's making
a joke about this other woman who can't
who is confusing two very different
black men ok she's kind of making the
joke on the other woman Hillary's been
here before she's made some of these
racial jokes before and they've fallen
flat so I'm confused as to why she would
keep doing it a few years ago she went
on stage with New York Mayor Bill
DeBlasio
and they made a joke about how they
showed up late because they were running
on CP time said CP you mean colored
people time and she says no cautious
politician time ha ha ha the joke being
that that black people show up late ok
this fell flat apologies were demanded
and then she made this one again and
this joke wasn't scripted this one just
kind of came from her and she said I
know they all look alike don't they ha
ha ha I'm not hitting her for making a
racial joke I actually think the world
would be a lot better off if we felt
more comfortable making racial jokes
about everybody but black people Italian
people Irish but I think it's a little
looser people people always kind of
laugh and giggle at these jokes in
private you know the you make a joke for
like for instance when you make a joke
about an Irishman drinking a little too
much people laugh about them in private
and then they have to pretend that they
don't laugh about them and then public
and they're very solemn I think we'd be
better off if we could all loosen up a
little bit but it's Hillary Clinton it
for the Democratic Party it's the left
that is pushing this neo Puritanism it
was calling for
Trump racist I mean Hillary Clinton
herself calls Donald Trump racist
they're calling him a bigot
they're calling an anti-semite they're
calling him all of these things they're
the one making these comments they're
the one saying that black it's
surprising when black people do a good
job it's surprising when Indians do a
good job black people all look alike
they're the ones making these comments
Don Lemon over they so race obsessed and
and this by the way is why they're so
fluent in white nationalism you know
they see white nationalists everywhere
white nationalism which is a
contradiction in terms
there has never been a nation of the
whites there isn't a capital W whites
actually one of the arguments against
nationalism is that in the white
continent in Europe there are so many
different peoples and so many different
nations that they're always fighting and
killing each other so we need to unify
them in some way ironically white
nationalism is anti nationalists but I
digress the reason that the left is so
fluent in what all of these racist
people say Richard Spencer David Duke
all of these these comments on in the
sewers of the internet where 50 people
read what the blogs say is because they
themselves are obsessed with race it's
all they can possibly see and
conservatives don't really pay attention
to it how many conservatives do you know
who could explain what the alternative
right is you know I did a video for
Prager about the alternative right I had
to really research it I did dig pretty
far down and read certain books and read
this and that because we just don't see
it we don't talk about it we don't think
in that way at all but the left because
the alternative right is a mirror image
of the left and the left side entity
politics they are fluent in it they talk
about it all the time they can rattle
off what they these people say on their
message boards and in their blog posts
and wherever because they're so fluent
because it's so similar to the left it's
really bizarre you know and and the
media and Democrats here are making
they're humiliating themselves because
they automatically hate anything that
Trump does anything the Trump does they
have to react against and and they get
really tribal about it they get really
tribal they get really
protective of each other and they
humiliate themselves you know when you
get angry you get mad and you get stupid
I know you're on the edge of your seat
because Jon Stewart did something right
you can only see it if you go to daily
wire.com what do you get you get me you
get the Andrew Clavin show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you don't ask questions
in the mailbag you can't ask questions
in the conversation that's coming up and
get your mailbag questions in soon none
of that matters because you get a
leftist ears tumblr now I don't have my
leftist here's tumblr today because I
like beer and I still like beer I like
beer and sometimes I drink a little too
much beer well you know what sometimes I
drink a little too much leftist tears
and I get very dehydrated because
they're extremely salty so you need
balance in your life but go because it's
the only FDA approved vessel to hold
those salty and delicious leftist Cheers
we will be right back stay tuned for a
lot more
John Stuart gets this completely right
on the media I know it's shocking
he'd about once a year John Stuart would
get something right when he was on TV
he's not on TV anymore
but he gets this right he's talking to
CNN about how the media are reacting to
Trump how they're covering Trump how
they're being triggered by Trump and he
puts it right in their face here he is
do you think because obviously we're all
caught up in this sort of daily Trump
fest
I mean every single newspaper every
radio station every bit of social media
you've got to make money to man you got
electric bills you got food you know
this guy is he's giving you all cash the
cash flow and the Trump era for for
these TV stations and I say that might
have been an issue and maybe it still is
an issue for the people who are the bean
counters but three the journalists we I
think believe that our job is to
navigate the truth and to do the
fact-checking and all the rest of it so
I think that's what motivates I think
the journalists have taken it personally
okay they're personally wounded and
offended by this man he baits them and
they dive in and what he's done well I
thought is appealed to their own
narcissism to their own ego because what
he says is these are the been the
journalists and I would say we are noble
we are honorable how dare you sir and
they take it personally exactly right
just think of Jim Acosta when when was
the last time that Jim Acosta wasn't
looking in a mirror
because when he's on camera you know the
camera lens is a little mirror he can
see himself I think when that camera
goes off he immediately just turns to
the Mary says oh there you are Jim there
you're a great American you're strong
you're good enough smart enough and gosh
darn it people like you that is what the
media have become because they've made
it all about themselves one of the rules
in journalism is you're supposed to not
make yourself the story you are not the
story you're supposed to be covering the
story but because these people are all
narcissistic bobbleheads they make
themselves the story they want to be the
center of attention and Donald Trump is
more than happy to oblige because the
American people don't like these
news anchors they don't like Jim Acosta
they don't like them one little bit they
don't like people going on television
and telling them they're being objective
and actually just spewing left-wing
propaganda the American people don't
like it when you boof on their leg and
tell them that it's windy they don't
want this one little bit boof boof
senator its flatulence we're a sixteen
senator that's what it it's that's how
you define it they don't they don't like
that either I mean they don't like it to
become a circus they don't want their
politics to be made into a circus and he
recognizes that and the other thing
Stewart recognizes is that the media
secretly love Donald Trump because he
makes them so much money and this is why
as we go into the midterms
I think conservatives have their
priorities in order
I think they saw the lynch mob that went
after Brett Kavanaugh they've seen the
tremendous gains of the Trump era
economically and foreign policy
judicially and they're saying we want
more of this and they're shutting out
the noise they're putting on their
blinders they're going in they're gonna
get the job done the left has been
really distracted whipped into a frenzy
and it's because they believe the
mainstream media who were milking them
to make money there is a compilation
online it goes on for several minutes
I'll just give you the first little
taste of it
this goes chronologically from August
2017 up through the present day just
listen to how MSNBC CNN all of these
other networks are covering President
Trump in the White House day today
beginning in August 2017 the tipping
point I know we've said it over and over
you think this is a tipping point and
over and over this is a tipping point
and over and over making news president
Trump off the rails there's a beginning
of the end today the beginning of the
end it reminds me a lot of the last days
of Nixon breaking news tonight new bombs
show this is the beginning at the end
the beginning of the end the walls are
closing in the walls closing in breaking
overnight bombshells there's a very
dramatic day and I think it might be
near a tipping point you think this is a
tipping point this is unbelievable this
is remarkable have you ever seen
anything like this his presidency is
crippled
December 1st 2017 you can mark it down
this is the day that everything changed
we begin with the bombshell the
beginning of the end is the beginning of
the end what is it is it the beginning
of the end it's now it's the middle of
the end because the beginning of the end
was I guess in August 2017 then
September was still the beginning of the
end then October was the middle of the
beginning of the end then November then
December the video goes on for two more
minutes probably I couldn't if that just
takes you to December 2017 that takes
you to basically a year ago they keep
promising this is the end this is the
beginning of the end for Trump breaking
bombshell and guess what it's not it's
not the beginning of the end it's not
even the the pre-show of the beginning
of the end it has not right now the big
scoop the big story which Politico got
is that a special counsel Bob Muller may
have subpoenaed Donald Trump to appear
before the grand jury so then you've got
Donald Trump he'll be speaking on the
record he could be he could be caught in
a perjury trap here if he speaks loosely
and that what Politico is reporting is
quote since mid-august he may Muller may
have been locked in proceedings with
Trump and his lawyers over a grand jury
subpoena in secret litigation that could
tell us by December whether the
president will testify before Muller's
grand jury okay maybe this is true that
could be the case I don't know whether
it's true or not what I do know is it's
not the beginning of the end it's not
the beginning of the end because I just
don't believe it anymore
I sort of believed at the first 7,000
times they told me this would happen and
then it hasn't they are just making
money as Jon Stewart says they are
raking in money on this hysteria but the
hysteria is false I talked to my friends
on the left you know been traveling
around the country doing these speeches
and when I stopped by New York I was
talking to my friends on the left and I
couldn't believe that they actually
believed this stuff they actually
believe that Trump is doing the bidding
of Vladimir Putin they don't know
anything about the Russian but they just
believe it because they heard it because
it's breaking news and it's the
beginning of the end they believe all of
it
it isn't true they're milking you to get
money don't buy it
so we'll see what happens President
Trump might have to appear you know the
reason we haven't heard a lot from
Muller until today is that you're you're
really not supposed to release damaging
information about political candidates
before an election this is long-standing
goj practice it's why the Democrats were
very upset at James Comey before the
2016 presidential election is that he
came out to cover his own rear when he
thought Hillary was gonna win and came
out and said there are some more
questions about Hillary Clinton you're
really not supposed to do that so Bob
malar has thus far honored it but you do
have to wonder how does this story come
out today just a few days six days
before the midterm elections maybe it
was just regular shoe on the ground old
fashion reporting from Politico maybe
some people are leaking some things I
don't really know the timing is a little
suspect though either way we'll see what
happens
it'll be more great TV we'll all tune in
to see Trump testify and it won't be the
beginning of the end I am telling you
that so right before we go I have to
point out that so far Christine Blasi
Ford the one woman who testified against
Brett Kavanaugh who we were told had
nothing to gain from testifying before
the Senate Judiciary Committee nothing
to gain everything to lose nothing to
gain she's made a million dollars on
this whole charade
she made a million bucks through her go
fund me accounts she's now getting book
deals and book offers from people she's
making a lot of money on this whole
thing but she's not the only one a Brett
Kavanagh has just been offered through a
GoFundMe campaign six hundred thousand
dollars why I have no idea he's a
federal judge he has enough money he
paid off those baseball tickets on his
credit cards that Democrats were giving
him trouble for before they decided to
invent ridiculous sexual harassment
claims but they're offering him this
money on GoFundMe I really love this
story one because it's absurd why why
are either of these people getting money
on go
why are you who works for your money
giving money to this college professor
with 17 different stories about how
prick Kavanagh looked the wrong way at
her in 1742 and ii even
even more insane why are you presumably
conservative people giving money to
judge Cavanaugh he has enough money he's
a federal judge he's doing just fine why
are you doing that it's one it's because
we're too rich too it's because we feel
that this is the best way to express our
political point of view this is a way
that we can express our political
beliefs and that we can engage in
political speech and this is my favorite
part of the story because after this
after Christine Ford makes a million
bucks on her stories after Brett
Kavanagh has to refuse six hundred
thousand dollars because it would be a
gross ethic violation so that money is
going to charity I never want to hear a
left-winger complain about Citizens
United again I never what you know we
heard all the way up to Barack Obama
Democrats complaining money isn't speech
money isn't speech citizens united was
wrongly decided because money isn't
political speech then what are these
GoFundMe campaigns charity no you're
you're not donating because they're
destitute on the street because of your
Christian charity you walked by these
two bums when they said please spare a
little change sir you're doing it
because of your political point of view
and your political advocacy and because
they're advancing your political agenda
it's political speech and it is the
perfect distillation of money being
speech we all know that money is speech
some people who are pretending otherwise
no longer can pretend that way and I
will point out justice Kavanagh has is
giving all that money to charity he's
not gonna take that money it would be
wrong to take that money he's refusing
it and the guy who organized the
GoFundMe is donating it to charity
where's Christine Ford's money going
where's that million dollars going where
where's her book deal money going that
gonna charity something tells me not
will have to see all right it's time for
me to go finish my beer because I like
beer and even after this show I still I
still like beer
sometimes I drink a little too much
sometimes I go a little too long on my
podcast you ever go too long on your
podcast audience do you do you make sure
you get your mailbag questions in we'll
have that tomorrow in the meantime have
a very happy Halloween and I will see
you tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Knowles oh is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you